wir sind zurück im bundestag und wären
die gelegenheit mit dem bundeswahlleiter
zu sprechen der tiere danke dass sie
zeit haben was passiert jetzt rund eine
stunde vor schließung der wahllokale was
machen sie jetzt
haben jetzt voll stärke erreicht und
warten auf die dann ab 18 uhr
einlaufenden ergebnisse aus dem
landeswahlleitung 'nen und insofern ist
jetzt alles ab acht stellung aber wir
haben auch viele fragen von bürgern die
uns noch etwas fragen und das muss alles
beantwortet werden was fragen sich die
bürger denn die meisten ja zum beispiel
warum es zu langen warteschlangen vor
lokalen kommt warum armin laschet wahl
ist eine ganz beliebte frage dass
antworten wir und ich glaube das ist
auch gut so dass die bürger von der
bundeswehr leitung direkt eine antwort
bekommen armin laschet hat ja seinen
stimmzettel falsch gefaltet sodass man
sehen konnte was er gewählt hat was
sagen sie dazu wir sind alle nicht
überrascht dass frau laschet und herr
laschet dies so gewählt haben die wahl
vorschriften sind eindeutig man soll das
so ist wo gefaltet dass man es nicht
sieht eigentlich hätte der wahlvorstand
das sagen müssen so geht's nicht bitte
sie kriegen einen neuen wahlzettel
vernichten sie ihren aber ich glaube das
kann mal in der aufregung wenn
spitzenpolitiker kommen medien kommt
kann das alles passieren insofern sollte
man es nicht überbewerten auf jeden fall
die stimme ist gültig wie sieht es denn
mit der wahlbeteiligung insgesamt
ausfallen verglichen zur letzten
bundestagswahl einer halben stunde haben
wir ja was dazu gesagt die ist ungefähr
fünf prozent an der urne weniger dafür
glaube ich haben wir aber flächendeckend
eine höhere briefwahlbeteiligung und
insofern gehe ich aus dass wir die 72
prozent der letzten bundestagswahl
erreichen werden ich denke sogar in
manchen bereichen wörter sind wissen
darüber legen was verändert sich denn
genau auch für ihre arbeit angesichts
dieses hohen brief fall anteils die
logistik die alle treffen dass nicht nur
die bundeswehr leitung will ich das
machen ja im prinzip die kreiswahl
leitungen die müssen einfach in der
vorbereitung dass die
briefwahlunterlagen zum bürger kommen
und wieder zurück müssen vorbereitungen
getroffen werden und dann dauert es
natürlich briefwahlunterlagen
auszuzählen und vorzubereiten für die
auszählung das dauert etwas länger also
kann man wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen
dass wir ein bisschen später
in der nacht oder besser in den frühen
morgenstunden sein werden sie insgesamt
dafür dass man den zeitraum in dem brief
fall möglich ist verkürzt es gab ja auch
ein bisschen aufregung darüber dass in
einigen umfragen
menschen noch einmal befragt wurden die
ihre stimme per briefwahl schon
abgegeben haben ich habe das auch teil
des vg kassel zur kenntnis genommen das
steht einer bundeswahl leitung nicht zu
sagen wir müssen das so oder so in
gesetzen regeln das müssen die
parlamente entscheiden aber ich glaube
schon es gibt diskussionsrunde
erörterung bedarf aus der situation der
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat mal
gesagt die briefwahl ist sozusagen die
zweite säule aber die ohne wahl ist
eigentlich das leitbild und wenn wir am
ende jetzt 40 bis 50 prozent
briefwahl erreichen dann weiß ich nicht
mehr ob das mit dem leitbild noch
übereinstimmt aber das muss die politik
glaube ich entscheiden und nicht die
wahlleitung wir sind die schiedsrichter
der regeln die die parlamente warum
vielen dank herr thiel dann sind wir mal
weiter gespannt und damit erstmal zurück
zu meiner kollegin michaela kolster